the Trump administration is escalating
the trade war between the world's two
largest economies by slapping new
tariffs on Chinese imports the plan will
impose a 25% tax on additional 16
billion dollars in Chinese goods
starting August 23rd industrial products
like steam turbines and iron girders are
targeted last month u.s. tariffs on 34
billion dollars worth of Chinese imports
went into effect China has been
retaliating in America's lobster
industry is feeling the impact the US
exported more than 142 million dollars
worth of lobster to China last year
that's up from about one hundred and
eight million dollars in 2016 but that
number is expected to take a big hit
after China roughly double tariffs on
live US seafood Don Dahler went to Long
Island Maine to see how lobster
producers are getting squeezed out
that's a pleasant surprise it's just
after sunrise in the Gulf of Maine and
lobster fisherman Steve train is
preparing for today's catch train has
harvested lobster from these waters for
over 40 years a livelihood made viable
in part because of trade relationships
with countries like China where North
Atlantic lobster is popular it's gonna
hurt our market well making less every
year than we did years ago and now we've
got another something else hanging over
our head in June the Trump
administration announced a 25% tariff on
Chinese goods Beijing responded with its
own 25 percent tariff on a list of goods
that includes live lobster at the same
time China has lowered its tariffs on
Canadian lobster imports to 7% making
them more attractive to Chinese buyers
Stephanie Nadeau distributes the lobster
caught by fishermen like Steve Trane
she says that Chinese buyers used to
account for 35% of her sales but since
the tariffs have come in to the fact
that market has virtually dried up there
are no lobsters going
mainland China they've stopped they've
started because the prices went up
because of the terrace yes and then we
have the identical product to Canada my
lobsters have a 25% tax which is a $2
difference is an insurmountable
difference Maine currently produces more
lobster than any other US state or
Canadian province and for now most of
Steve trans lobster can still be sold
domestically but as the Trump
administration takes aim at Chinese
imports many here feel that the lobster
industry has become collateral damage
they've taken our business and I don't
know how we'll ever get it back the
longer this goes on the more difficult
and we make it too for us to resume our
relationships with our customers for CBS
this morning Don Dahler Long Island
Maine consequences you see the report
dollars that's a lot and that's a big
difference